opioids are drugs that are prescribed to
treat moderately severe or severe pain
fentanyl is a strong synthetic opioid it
may be prescribed to treat severe pain
from cancer or after surgery
its potency or strength is up to 50
times that of heroin an illegal opioid
and 100 times that of morphine another
opioid used to treat severe pain in
order to understand how opioids like
fentanyl work it's important to know how
your body feels pain the process begins
when something harmful happens to your
body information about this harm is
converted to a nerve signal the signal
passes along nerves to your spinal cord
and brain
in your brain the signal is perceived as
pain
fentanyl affects how you feel pain
it attaches to structures called opioid
receptors these receptors are found in
cells in your brain spinal cord and
other areas of your body fentanyl acts
on these receptors to make you feel less
pain
fentanyl can also have other effects on
your body
for example it may give you an intense
short-term high and feelings of extreme
happiness
fentanyl also activates the reward
pathway in your brain this causes
certain parts of the reward Pathway to
release a chemical called dopamine
scientists think dopamine helps you
remember how good you felt while taking
Fentanyl and makes you want to keep
taking it
this link between remembering things
that make you feel good with a desire to
do them again is an important part of
developing addiction
fentanyl may also slow your breathing
and make you feel nauseated
and it may cause reduced motion of your
intestines resulting in constipation
there are two types of fentanyl the
pharmaceutical form and the illicit or
illegal form while the pharmaceutical
form of fentanyl may be prescribed to
treat severe pain it can be taken in
ways that weren't prescribed such as
taking too many taking them to feel high
or giving them to someone else
the illicit form is made and sold
illegally on the drug Market people take
it because it produces a strong high and
intense feelings of well-being
fentanyl is a dangerous and addictive
opioid because of its potency
as with any opioid fentanyl addiction is
a brain disease where you have an
overwhelming craving for the drug you
can't stop taking the drug despite the
harm it may cause you if you do stop
taking the drug you feel sick this
sickness is called withdrawal
fentanyl withdrawal symptoms can be
severe which is why many people don't
stop taking it
symptoms may include anxiety
bone and muscle pain
increased heart rate
high blood pressure
vomiting and diarrhea
sweating and chills
and sleep problems
a fentanyl overdose means you've taken
too much of the drug which can cause
life-threatening symptoms or even death
depending on your body size and how long
you've been taking the drug as little as
two milligrams can kill you
most cases of Overdose and death from
fentanyl in the United States are
related to taking the illicit form and
because fentanyl is strong and cheap to
make illicitly it's often mixed with
other illegal drugs
such as heroin
cocaine
and methamphetamines
this is dangerous because a person may
take it without meaning to which may
result in accidental overdose or death
the symptoms of fentanyl overdose
include
confusion constricted or pinpoint pupils
feeling sleepy or losing consciousness
weak slowed or stopped breathing
inability to talk
lymph body cold clammy skin with
discolored skin lips and nails slowed or
stopped heartbeat and death
according to the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention over 150
Americans die each day from opioid
overdoses including Fentanyl
if you have questions about fentanyl or
if you are someone Close to You needs
help for an opioid use disorder talk to
your Healthcare practitioner